i'm going to talk about one of the most
significant figures in western history
and that's gaius julius caesar
now what we'll see is his life really
marks the transition from
official roman republic to the roman
empire and i say official roman republic
because it's important to keep in mind
even at the time of julius caesar's
birth at the beginning of the first
century bce the roman republic already
looked something like an empire you
might remember that during the punic
wars they were able to take over
carthage's possessions in africa and in
spain at the end of the third punic war
they were also and this wasn't part of
the pubic war but they were separately
in 146 bce were also able to take over
greece
so any state that has conquered these
people that have different languages
cultures and they don't have the same
rights as the citizen of those
of the citizens of those
of that state well this is by most
definitions what would constitute an
empire but at the during julius caesar's
birth and during his life it would rome
was still officially a republic and
that's referring more to its form of
government you had a very powerful
senate you had these consuls who were
elected for these one-year terms and
there were all of these checks and
balances as we'll see his life
especially the end of his life marks the
transition to an empire in which there
is a roman emperor who holds most of the
power but let's go into the story and
there's going to be a significant cast
of characters here that i'm going to go
into
so by 60 bce julius caesar is roughly 40
years old and he's already a significant
figure in the republic he is born to a
patrician family he rises up through the
ranks he's a charismatic figure
and in 60 he forms a triumvirate with
two other powerful figures in rome so
you have this is julius caesar of course
and he forms this triumvirate which
later gets known as the first
triumvirate with crassus who is the
richest man in rome at the time and is
believed to be one of the richest men in
roman history and you can see crassus is
a good bit older than julius caesar he's
born more than a decade before julius
caesar and he also forms this alliance
with pompey who is also a little bit
older than julius caesar and is a
significant military figure a general in
the roman republic and this first
triumvirate even though it wasn't an
official it's not an official government
group it allowed them to really uh hold
the power of the roman republic and to
really move and hold the power within
the senate this first triumvirate and
and even though julius caesar was a
patrician news from the nobility
they had populist tendencies they wanted
to do things for the people you could
view them as in certain ways progressive
they wanted to do land redistribution
versus kind of the conservatives who
wanted to hold the power in the
aristocracy
and so this first triumvirate is able to
use their influence to put julius caesar
in as consul for the year 59
bce
and as we as i just mentioned at the
beginning of this video there are two
consoles the other one was a figure
named bibulus but julius caesar is able
to dominate the position and he's a very
powerful consul and he tries to put all
of these populist reforms into place so
this is already starting to cause a lot
of tension in the senate between the
populists and the conservatives
now after he's done his one-year term
he becomes pro-consul which you can view
as a military governor and he's given
regions that border gaul so he's given
what would be considered southern france
right over here he or the or border with
the golic tribes i guess you could say
the near the italian app alps these are
two of the regions two of the three
regions that he's given to governor to
given to govern and he uses his position
as military governor as pro council
pro-consul
to expand the territories into gaul to
take on these golic tribes
now the the
the gauls or these gaelic tribes they
were they're super fragmented there was
many many of them plutarch says on the
order of 300 of these gallic tribes they
were militarily fairly sophisticated
they were many historians say comparable
to the romans but it was their
fragmentation that allowed julius caesar
to go after them so over the course of
his governorship of his position as
pro-consul you also have the golic wars
or the gaelic wars and that's what i
have depicted here in red from 58 bce to
52 bce and they end here in elisha where
julius caesar's legions are able to win
decisively and that is the end and he's
able to take all of this territory for
rome
now while that was happening in 53
bce
so in 53
bce which is right over here in 53 this
is 53 52 yeah this is 53 bce crassus who
you might remember was part of this
first triumvirate he's off here he's off
over here in the east fighting the
parthians you might remember the
parthians this is now the the parthian
persian empire they're the they're the
successors of the seleucids who are the
successor of alexander the great who is
the successor in persia of the
achaemenid empire and while fighting the
parthians he is killed crassus is killed
while fighting the parthians which
breaks up this first triumvirate and
then pompey switches sides he switches
sides over to the conservative side so
now instead of becoming instead of being
one of julius caesar's allies he becomes
one of his opponents
and so julius caesar he's victorious
he's able to conquer these powerful
gallic tribes
plutarch according to him
julius caesar's legions fought over or
on the order of three million gauls i
don't know if those tur if those numbers
are exaggerations they sound like they
might be a little bit of one of which
one million were killed and one million
were enslaved 800 cities were destroyed
300 tribes were over were overrun and
those might be exaggerations they
probably were but it tells you the scope
of what julius caesar did when he took
over when he took over gaul so he's
already this very charismatic figure he
was consul but he's not he's
controversial figure in the senate he
has these more populist tendencies while
there's a lot of these conservatives in
the senate
the first triumvirate breaks pompey
switch sides he's he's able to take over
gaul and so you can imagine as he is
now
victorious
the senators are worried they're like
you know this this guy if he comes back
to rome he might have too much power and
he might have too much power to do the
things that we as especially the
conservatives don't want him to do you
know this land redistribution and all of
the things like that and so they tell
him in 50 bce so this is 50 bc let me
circle that in 50
bce they tell him to leave his proconsul
position disband his army and return to
rome
now julius caesar is thinking to himself
wait you know i
i just did all of this i might be you
know these people are afraid of me if i
go without my
title without my army who knows what
they're going to do to me when they go
when i go back to rome so he says well
i'm faced with a i either go back with
without my armies or go with my armies
and so he decides to do the ladder he
takes his armies and he crosses the
rubicon river now crossing the rubicon
i'm going to write this down
crossing
the rubicon is now a phrase that we have
in our culture that means you know
you're you're gone past the point of no
return there's a famous quote described
to julius caesar once he crossed the
rubicon as the die has been cast it's
the point of no return and this was a
really big deal because it was illegal
for a governor general a pro-counsel
to take their legions outside of
territories they're governed and this
wasn't just any region he was taking it
into the italian peninsula he was taking
it to rome so this was very very very
illegal so the senators weren't happy
about this so they said hey pompey you
have to go you have to go face your
former ally
julius caesar now pompey doesn't know
that julius caesar only has one legion a
legion is about four or five thousand
soldiers he's thinking surely if julius
caesar is crossing the rubicon he must
have a trick up his sleeve he's already
had this you know conquering gaul he's
established himself as this uh
significant military figure and so
pompey says you know senators i'm not
going to keep them from going to rome
just yet i'm going to go over to the
east
into greece where we can build up our
armies and make sure we are prepared to
retake rome and so the senators aren't
too happy about this but a good number
of them says okay well if if you're
going to leave then we're going to go
with you and so julius caesar is
actually able to in 49 bce take rome but
this isn't the end and we will continue
it in the next video because as you as i
just said the power of rome has now
moved over to greece a good number of
the powerful senators you have pompey
and his armies that are in greece pompey
controls significant fractions of the
navy and so a civil war has now broken
out in the roman republic